-Hey, I like this.
I'm liking the mustache.
-Ooh. This old thing?
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-What's going down?
-Little lip jewelry.
-Wow. That's not
what you call it at all.
It looks good.
What is it for? A role?
-No. No, this is for real life.
-Oh. Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-No, here -- Okay, it's actually
really -- It's kind of crazy.
So, I never intended
to have this.
I don't think
I look good with it.
But I'm keeping it.
-Okay.
-We -- My wife --
My wife has a friend
who's this very famous
English singer.
Let's just say, right?
-Okay. Sure.
-Okay? So she throws
these birthday parties.
And they're kind of lavish.
-Adele?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Did I nail it?
-♪ Hello from the other side ♪
-Yeah, every time.
So -- I sing it over the fence.
Anyway, so, she's like,
"Hey, she's having this
birthday party. We have to go."
And I'm like, "Okay, we'll go
to the birthday party."
I'm like -- And so she comes to
the day of the birthday party,
she's like, "Listen, the theme
for the birthday party
is 1970s New Year's."
And I'm like, "Who the --
throws a 1970s New Year's
birthday party?"
Like, and I find out
on the day of, right?
-I love that you just
censored yourself.
That's amazing.
No one's ever done that.
-I have children.
-Oh, my God. That was --
I've never seen anyone --
do that ever.
-Oh, my God! You don't --
do that with the kids?
-I don't -- do that ever!
-I mean, this -- is crazy!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
-So, she's like, "It's
a 1970s birthday party.
I'm like, "Oh, well, we were
both on the '70's Show.'
I think we got this," right?
-Of course, yeah.
-So we can put
this thing together.
So I get the bell bottoms out.
I break them out.
And I'm putting them with some
good boots and like a vest
and a scarf tied around the neck
and like a thing.
And I'm looking in the mirror.
And I've got a beard going.
And I'm like,
"Oh, I'm going '70s stache.
Like, it's got to happen."
-Ah.
-So I whittle everything down.
And I'm -- And it's thin.
I mean, it's like
a high school boy
trying to grow a mustache thin.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But it looks great
for the party. Right?
-Oh, yeah, perfect.
-So, we show up at the thing.
And my wife is in
this timeless jumper
that could have be from any --
So we show up.
And I'm looking around.
And nobody else
is in 1970s anything. Right?
And I'm like, "What kind of --
What the hell --"
The theme for the party's
1930s New Year's.
And I look like Burt Reynolds
from -- "Boogie Nights."
And I'm like, "This is a joke."
And I'm, like, walking around.
And what, are you gonna be like,
"I got the decade wrong"?
So, I'm just playing it off
like this is how I'm doing it
these days.
And I'm like, "What's up, Jay-Z?
Yeah, this is my thing now."
[ Laughter ]
And it was really awkward.
-Yeah.
-And so now it's a spite
'stache. And I'm keeping it.
-Oh, yeah.
-This is payback.
-It's a spite 'stache. Yeah.
-It's a full blown
spite 'stache.
And now she likes it.
So now I can't get rid of it.
-Wow. No, it looks good.
You can pull anything off.
-Thank you.
-Come on. Please. How are the --
How is the family?
How are the kids?
-I feel like a baron.
-It's like kind of
a little baron --
-I'm going to get
a little tweaky,
so I can be like a real baron.
-Are you gonna really?
Is that your next move?
-I'm thinking about it.
-Get the mustache wax
and go for a little tweak on it?
-Maybe.
-Yeah. Last time I was here,
you told me to lose my mustache.
-You've got -- I mean, that was
a -- That was a beef cake.
-Yeah, it was a thing, yeah.
-I mean, it was beef-cakey.
-It was a lot, yeah.
It got out of control real fast.
-Mine's like an aristocrat.
-Yeah.
-It's a little thinner,
because that's just
how it comes in.
-Yeah, mine was like a co-star.
-Yeah.
-It was a co-star.
It was too much.
Too much stache.
-It was strong.
-It was pretty strong, yeah. But
you talked to me. You came on.
You didn't lie. You were like,
"It doesn't look good.
Yeah, get rid of it."
-It was, like, Bulgarian.
-Yeah. Alec Baldwin
yelled at me, too.
He came on, he goes,
"What's that for?
What are you doing?
Are you doing a bit?
I'll do a bit with you."
I go, "I'm not doing a bit."
He's like, "Well, why are you
wearing that mustache?"
I go, "This is my mustache."
He goes, "It looks terrible.
Why would you do that?"
You can't say that.
Talking about my face.
-Your face is handsome.
-Thank you. I appreciate --
-Yeah, every time I go in
to my business manager,
I have to look at your face.
Did you know that?
-No.
-You've got -- There's a poster
of you and Drew Barrymore
in the bathroom.
And every time I take a leak --
It's, like, signed like,
"Put this in your bathroom.
Love, Jimmy."
And every time I go there
to go to the bathroom --
-Well, wait, no.
You know what I wrote on there.
I wrote, "Don't hang this
in the bathroom."
-It's in the bathroom! And I got
to look at you every time I pee.
And it's a little weird for me.
-Well, it's just an odd thing.
'Cause I sign things for people.
And I go, "Just do me a favor,
don't hang this
in a weird spot."
-It's in the John.
-Oh, my God.
I'm going to call them tomorrow.
Silvaggio --
I'll call that dude.
I want to talk to you
about this.
'Cause I think
this is fascinating.
I don't know if you guys know
this about Ashton Kutcher here,
but he's one of the top
tech investors in the world.
And you're really great at it.
You pick some good stuff.
You're a taste-maker.
And I didn't know -- When I --
I think I met you --
This has got to be 10 years ago
when I first started
talking to you about this.
I'm like, "I just know you
as the actor."
And I thought you were just
kind of goofy.
I don't know. And fun.
And you're like, "No, dude,
you get this," blah, blah,
And you started getting into it.
I'm like, "Whoa, I can't even
hold my own against you."
You know what you're doing, man.
-We moonlight as technologists,
you and I.
-We really do.
-This is our thing.
-But you hit homers, dude,
I mean --
-We're doing alright.
-Airbnb, Spotify.
I mean, this is --
-Yeah, we're having fun.
-Uber.
-Yeah.
-Ashton, how did you
get into this?
Did you know that you were
good at this?
-I just started using the stuff.
I mean, I was like one --
I was early on Twitter
and started using that.
-Yeah
-And just started -- I just
started using all these things.
And I was like,
"This is fantastic."
And then just sort of
found a knack for it.
And then after a while,
the track record is
what the track record is.
But you kind of never look back.
And we just keep looking for
the next thing that's wonderful.
-I love that you do that,
though.
-It's really fun.
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-I met with like two companies
in New York today.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's amazing.
-Yeah, 10 years ago,
you were telling me
that you were meeting
with this guy.
And I go, "Ashton Kutcher.
That's just fantastic.
I never knew
this part about you."
-I met with this company
this morning that's in New York
right underneath your nose.
It's called Noom.
And it's like a --
-I know Noom.
-It's unbelievable!
-It's a weight loss thing.
-It's unbelievable
what they're building.
-I clearly don't have the app.
But I mean --
-It's a weight loss thing.
[ Laughter ]
-"I've been using Noom
for about four weeks now."
-"We've been really stocking up
on Noom as of late."
-"Please get Jimmy
to sign up to Noom."
-Before. After.
-Are you doing -- So are you
going to be investing in Noom?
-I think so. I like them.
-Wow.
-I don't know. I mean,
we're, like, working things --
We're seeing what -- You know,
because they've already
raised money
in the thing.
But I really like the company.
I think they're doing
incredible things.
They're helping a lot of people.
-I love that you're doing that.
And just gives --
I don't know, I just -- I think
it's awesome that you do that.
'Cause I look up to you
a little bit.
I go, "Look at Ashton
just crushing it."
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-I'm psyched, buddy.
Let's talk about
your second job, acting.
[ Laughter ]
"The Ranch," congratulations.
This Friday is a whole slew
of brand-new shows.
-Brand-new shows, yes.
-This is the longest running
multi-cam sitcom on Netflix.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty cool.
You're making history.
-That is pretty cool.
-That's fun.
-They told me that.
They told me that. And I didn't
even really realize it.
We had shot like 80 episodes
or something.
I didn't even realize it.
I was like, "Wow."
I mean, you know, it's like --
Time sort of just goes by.
And you just keep working
and working and working.
And you look back and you go,
"Wow, what happened?"